we've been here before no surprise
school
the dog
run inside
reckless rain falls in
from 343 industries studio head dan are
you
since the release of the original Halo
Wars seven years ago one of the top asks
from fans has been to continue the
adventures of the spirit of fire in Halo
Wars to the crew wake to find themselves
orbiting an ancient alien construct
known as the ark here they face a deadly
new faction known as the banished and
their chief the brute warlord a tree ox
a tree ox is an entirely new kind of
villain in our universe a brilliant
leader with the power of a massive army
behind him and he represents a menace
that the crew are completely unprepared
for in partnership with a claim
developer Creative Assembly we're proud
to bring halo wars 2 to Windows 10 and
xbox one on februari 21st 2017 halo wars
2 will be an Xbox play anywhere title
and will be playable here at e3 but you
guys don't have to wait to play Halo
Wars 2 we're launching a week-long beta
on xbox one right now
let's take a quick look at the action
that's coming your way with the beta
will see on the battlefield we detected
a large incoming enemy force a lot at a
club
[ __ ]
thank you go
enemy forces products that a location
our allies bathed another attack as I
predicted literally is nearly done for
protect the containers push that back
you